all right hello everyone I think I
should be live right now so that's the
first time that I'm doing a stream in
quite a long time been out for a while
so I'm gonna start by playing against
this guy black mine let's see what he
wants to do
oh he aborts right away okay that was
exciting
um modern auspicious start okay let me
spike and play some other people like
she done boo iliac or some other people
who are over 2700 right now who are
online um so so yeah I'm gonna start the
stream let's see okay good so I see a
few people are in the chat room now so
I'll write you guys you can ask me
plenty of questions while I'm while I'm
playing or not playing obviously depends
how many people are available at the
moment so um let's see all right no
one's accepting um so in the meantime if
you guys have questions or things you
can obviously just ask just in the on
twitch if you have specific questions so
alright so let's get the show going so
no one's accepted my challenge so let's
see maybe this an akai seven not okay so
here we go so this will be the first
game of this session it's at d4 Knight
64 he's six Knight c3
this should be former of the Bishop g5
play something a little bit different
it's a castle I'll click 3d file will
take probably take with a pawn bishop
III probably play Knight G - maybe h6
with h4
so c5 I'll play a three C for Bishop C -
alright see you guys are asking
questions in the chat all I'll get to
them when I'm not playing so just give
me a second sorry what's that
okay let's see okay so Queenie file my
castle okay a bunch of questions just
give me a second you guys at some some
since I'm actually the high rating at
the moment I kind of want to try and do
well today on the last few times I screw
my rating was a little bit low so this
time my rating at three thousand plus I
feel like I kind of have an obligation
to try and play play good chess or get
awfully Bishop e5 attack the knight
probably they'll put on d7 go Bishop d6
sorry about that just gonna it one
second
Queen b6 okay so with the bishop back on
g3 I have six in my play something he
wants to get this Bishop to a5 and d3 so
I've got to be pretty fast here I'm
gonna play I'll play work FB one try to
put some pressure on this pawn on b7 so
he goes Queen e6 let's play King F to
protect the pawn keep the bishop on this
long diagonal potentially so Queen a5
obviously wants 94 I'll just retreat
probably he'll go back Queenie six and
now he's gonna make me have to do
something radical well let's play this
buff - I am way down on time here it
should be noted so I've got to be a
little bit faster so let's see all right
Queen f5 I'm gonna play h3 maybe g4 at
some point just want to create some
space for my king
maybe Knight a for g4 maybe not maybe a
45 I think I'm just gonna play a 4 a 5
try to put some pressure on this b7 pawn
looking to get I'm gonna play kh2 now
get my king off g1 avoid any tricks and
probably I'll put my knight on a for
played Bishop age 4 knock smooth can you
turn on my plate this page for try to
maybe exchange maybe not but now he
played g5 so now he gave me this ee 5
square for the bishop potentially which
I'm gonna gladly take because now he's
got weaknesses on his King side too so
Bishop d6 rookie 6 and I have some
options but I'm way down on the clock so
I gotta just move fast so I'm gonna flip
c7 rookie a time when IG 3 and E 4 is E
4 knocks I'm trying to open this up
although I did a lot of Queen C sex that
was slight mistakes so takes takes
probably takes 24 still some play not
completely clear what's going on here
though King is wide open with these
pawns on a h6 g5 so it plays f6 no no I
think I'm gonna play what am I gonna
play here I'm gonna play Knight h5
trying to create some threats against
his pawn this rook it's all a little bit
loose here for blacks so Queen b6 up for
the King h1
get out of any discoveries on this
diagonal King up 7 no I'm gonna play
rook d1 probably Bishop e6 or King g6
now I can play a 4 and now it's getting
interesting so if he takes I take if he
takes on e4 I can take his rook because
this Queen is hanging so plays rook e8
I'm gonna play a 5 or not to the I'm
gonna play off 5 know looking out 7 of
course and then I'm gonna play g4 I
think
whoa what's it oh can you actually take
what noe 5 isn't it just checking it on
Queen g4 knocks booth it looks like
meeting one on Queen g4 so if he takes a
pawn on e5 I just play Queen e2 for in
checkmate so those nice fancy finish to
the first game so anyway in terms of
questions let's see so a couple of
people are asking me about
game against Magnus I didn't really have
a choice he kind of forced my hand if I
didn't make the draw I would have just
lost on the spot so a little bit
unfortunate but such is life that pretty
standard opening night g2 and then was
oh me too to help let's see if I've
tried to spice it up a little bit
create some imbalance in the structure
maybe he'll play d5 maybe Bishop d3 see
what he wants to do someone else was
asking me about crypto currencies I am
still in a few of them I don't know a
Bitcoin at the moment I own what do I
own at the moment I'm in a theory my
coin and a couple of the alt coins as
well so I'm still in it but I haven't
been paying much attention to it
of late DC 5 DC 5 and as far as losing
on the spot basically if I didn't play
Knight um 92 94 it was already just like
+1 minimum so it was just very bad for
black so I didn't really have much of a
choice so back to this game tonight g3
so he wants me move his Knight City he
can move the bishop and finish
development on the on the Kings side so
I'm not gonna do that I'm just gonna put
the fish 106
maybe stop him from doing anything on on
the Queen side like he maybe want to put
the bishop on on this a 1h a diagonal so
you did go Bishop d2 bishops III know
I'll just play I'm gonna play something
strange no I'll just play a 5 basically
here I'm gonna try to delay developing
this night as long as possible so that
he can't move this Bishop from f1
without hanging this pawn on g2 so as
far as my performance in the tournament
I'm pretty satisfied with that it could
have been a little bit better I would
have liked to have one of my game again
Slenderman but otherwise there isn't
much to complain about
certainly so it's completely fine as a
result mr. Bishop e3 knight c6 probably
hill castle here I'm gonna take the
knight play Knight d7 so basically why
his white spawns are a little bit weird
here he does is the two bishops but the
position looks pretty pretty standard so
if
so now I am going to take play d5 couple
options here
d5 Edie Edie rookie 1 and actually I
don't have to do anything because this
this if he takes I can just take with
the night so here's this good Bishop on
c3 I think I think I will take I'm gonna
take him play Knight a5 threaten Knight
e3 pawn on g3 couple different ideas
here so well let's see what we do so he
takes and now here I can take the pawn
I'm gonna take with the rook though
before work f7
so a five so he's really trying to force
force a position open I'm gonna play
work f8 now he takes I'll take with the
Queen and then g4 and eat c4
everything's a little bit loose here for
a white so I think I'm doing okay if he
takes I take with the rook I mean he's
got the problem that both these pawns
are hanging my a5 pawn is hanging at the
same time but his King is also over here
and I bought this really nice diagonal
so it takes I'll take d1 I will t I
don't see it where he ain't rough f8 I
think I'm okay takes takes and I think
I'm okay here rookie 7 ff7 is obviously
fine he doesn't want the draw Surrey
please we have to king g8 now if you
take say 5 I think he must play this
order because nobody takes a 5 I can
take c4 and he can't take c5 is ng 2
would hang so Queen f1 now I'll play a
for now the pawns on a light square so
this Bishop can attack my pawn and now
it's c4 pawn is small light squared
Bishop a6 Bishop c4
I am actually reading the reading the
twitch chat you guys so so I mean if I'm
getting low on time I'm gonna have to
focus on the game obviously but if
something like this is king up to now do
I play for the opposite color run game
or not so I was like he's asking me to
do it I normally I wouldn't do this but
I don't care I'm gonna I'm gonna take
the pawn see see if this is winning or
not because I'm getting I'm gonna end up
up two pawns here c-4 is hanging but
this might not be enough to win but
we'll see so Bishop e5 so I'm gonna put
the bishop on v3
so now these pawns are fixed you can
never do anything there's no counter
play and now I've got I've got two extra
pawns here it's off to color Bishop so
it's not easy but it feels like this
should probably be winning one one thing
Magnus would say is that fortresses are
not possible so based on that there
should be a winning endgame but we'll
see if that's actually the case here so
I'm gonna go king of five
you can't even attack my pawns here
they're all really well placed so I'm
gonna play H 5 H 4 I'm probably D 5 at
some point not right away I'm gonna put
the pitch funny for to attack this pawn
on G 2 and now I can't take the pawn
because I'm simply up a pawn here am I
not yeah I'm just up a pawn it's just
completely lost Kings you for king g3
King takes you to so okay so far so good
so all right as someone said analyze my
game today there isn't much to analyze
obviously it was just a very boring draw
so I'd be a little bit hard to do
someone else I'd play them on $4 tonight
I mean I don't know maybe Eric will
actually do a stream from the closing
ceremony cuz I know I mean Eric Eric
Hanson the main chest bra is here also
so I know they'll be there I'll probably
play them on or Eric something like
probably like four or five hours from
now but we'll see at any rate but until
that now I'm just gonna be streaming
problem tonight see six month eh four
try and make this interesting dish East
seven makes some sense DC for maybe so
please be southern just simply
rook to you when I'm not afraid of any
discovery on my queen here on h4 so I'll
just move the Queen over to g4 and and
threaten meet on g7 with this long
diagonal like something like that
so queen a5 I could take or not take
take or not to take yeah I know I don't
wanna think I'm gonna play a3 maybe b4
I'll let him him break it up so he takes
I'll take 2.5 no now I feel like I'm
starting to get the upper hand a little
bit so 96 as possible if I'm gonna go
Queen g3 it's 90 h5 I've got the square
on c7 also got this nice diagonal now as
well all kinds of little threats lumen
so rook c8 so now I can go 96 second
plane i th for I mean this looks really
really close to being extremely good for
me but I don't actually see the direct
way so I'm gonna play 90 for North takes
d4 so now maybe I can swing this rook
over to afford g4 maybe depending what
he does basically make his King feel
really uncomfortable here on g8 Henning
L rights will we ever witness a ragequit
you might witness a rage quit today I'd
say it's fairly unlikely but you know it
is possible certainly so 90 h5 is a good
move
actually this is a problem now I have
some issues here so I'm gonna play queen
chief for probably he'll take I'll take
a knight f6 gonna take and play d1 no
I'll play rook tough one because work do
you want a lot be 596 48 so pls rip da
I'll play a for maybe or not a for no I
don't really like my position here but
I'll go a for probably work d3 rugby one
work da King off one all right let's be
sick so he gives me time to bring my
king closer I think b6 was was slightly
inaccurate so now I mean I should be
quick enough with my King to get over
soon as works III I will play yeah I
don't really like e4 but how to get out
of this mess that I felt myself in um
yeah I will go eform
no Bishop d4 I'm gonna play e5 please
rip c2 but he gives me time now to play
e5 and after Bishop e7 I can just swing
my recorder to e4 e to so Bishop c5
rookie to and now I'm doing fine again
never work c3 I go rip d2 snow now I've
stabilized now I shouldn't be in any
trouble I don't like putting these pawns
on dark squares with the star square
bishop but I have to protect e5 and it
makes them those signs so he plays a5 up
with rook c1 threaten 95 maybe so you
see as it plays riff d5 and now I owe
all this exchange I'll play an endgame
Bishop again tonight with these with
these weak pawns on a 5 b6 I should be
fine g5 interesting take looking g2 king
of 3G for now maybe I'll try to create
an outside pass to H pawn possibly I'm
not sure yet
looking out 3 well just all just all
just outweigh him now no no play all
slow play it so g3 f5 wow that's
strangeness I'll take a looking out 3
and now because he exchanges off pawn
this should be winning I think if I can
bring my king to e4 I don't know why I
just resigned but anyone
so let's see 293 e6 if you guys have
questions obviously just ask merits
Holmes asks do I speak Japanese at the
moment I speak very badly so no I'm not
fluent in Japanese it's one of the few
languages that I'm interested in
learning at the moment but as with all
languages it's pretty hard if you don't
have the chance to get experience so I'm
not I mean I'm not not profession I know
some phrases but but nowhere near fluent
the only languages that I speak
reasonably well at the moment are
English Italian I speak some Spanish as
well
who doesn't but those really the only
languages at the moment so e46 is kind
of weird this bump b7 it's not
quite right it's a little bit out of
play
and someone says I'm getting inspired by
Magnus is b6 well actually people have
it wrong it's the other way around
Magnus was inspired by my b6 I think
because as anyone who's watched a stream
before knows I've played b6 far too many
times online too even even recall
probably a few hundred times at least if
not like a thousand
so trust-based says your English is
pretty good oh did I forget to sit I
speak English maybe I did maybe I did
actually forget to sit I speak English I
mean I do speak English amongst the
other languages so anyway all right
Queen d3 Knight f6 now he plays rook the
one he hangs a c4 pawn so oh the fgf a
chef I didn't see that that good play
like this but now after Bishop ca now
his pawns are very ugly like normally
why wants to play for c5 now he's made
these really ugly pawns here that don't
really make a lot of sense
so Knight bd7 hangs up five so I'm gonna
go night f d7 so now my rook protects
the pawn and now five and now I can
capture 95 I've also gotten eight c5
well a lot of good squares from eyepiece
is the only problem here is that my rook
and Knight and fish for a little bit
kind of misplace so Knight c5 miss
should be three I'll play Knight d7 and
now I've kind of solidified its now I
got a knight c5 now I'm finishing
development over here on the Queen side
I don't really want to exchange rooks at
the moment so rook a7 is there a threat
no I don't see how because I'm just
gonna play work f7 maybe move the knight
rook protects upon it f7 later on maybe
night if a knight c6 possibly teenage -
yeah now I'm gonna play Knight Fe just
try and put the knight on g6 so f e5 now
I've got a couple options here I can
take with the pawn or the bishop I'll
take with the pawn said he doesn't have
this Knight d4 Knight c6 or Knightly six
ideas and if you please d6 I just take
the pawn because I can put something on
e6 perv on Bishop d5
although I still think he's gonna
probably play d6 no he doesn't he plays
g4 so for a for even just take the pawn
maybe know what to do okay I don't see
it I'm gonna just drop upon make the pre
move in case it takes a knight not that
he will
P P Co loss
P kalasa 228 says how do you feel about
your game again Cheryl that was a pretty
interesting game pretty balanced
not a whole lot either side could have
done so I thought it was interesting I
thought share household be for a four
idea was quite quite novel and I
actually thought it was interesting it
was a very very interesting game so I
was
I enjoyed that game so gh3 maybe he'll
take maybe he won't
those fish brought three now I'm just
gonna treat my King said I don't allow
any like d6 or b6 weird stuff to happen
maybe Knight c5 here nah he's just he's
gonna play Knight g3 and try to play for
some kind of blockade but he is down to
pawns here and it's kind of I mean I
think I should just be batter here so
I'm gonna put it about five feet eggs
I'll take I mean two pawns is a lot I
did give him d6 I guess but he plays
Knight f6 that could be a problem okay
I'll take pics oh this is getting dicey
okay I'll play this b7 2016 8 just make
sure there are no checkmate so I can get
a Bishop to d6 I shouldn't be in down
much trouble so this would be 4 so he's
trying to just take I can play Bishop e7
give him the take I can play Queen d6
community 6 looks correct if I'm not
blundering checkmate somehow cleaning
off 7 Bishop f8 Knight f6 Bishop g7 just
like barely hanging on somehow rook e8
rook e8 is always okay I still don't see
it the rook because he's gonna play rook
e8 and then I play Bishop dat this is
very close I'm either completely finer
I'm just completely lost
so Queen e6 so he just wants to exchange
now okay but now now I'm gonna try to
meet him going the other way with Queen
off to play for the counter play
cleaning six was fine too but I think
was hard to win so Queen here six worked
d8 is his idea so now he's just trying
to
I don't know what he's trying to do but
I've got to start with it faster anyway
so I'm gonna go back to you seven
probably Queenie six maybe not I'm not
sure what he's gonna do so he does I'm
gonna go clean she five now attack the
knight try to cut him from the other way
on d2 we're not fine no Wendy too
although I don't have a mates right do I
teenage three it's all Chuck can't King
each one okay it's not about Chuck and
now I've got night off for Chuck 9h five
I know I should be in very good shape
that's a resigns so that was a really
close game I was a little bit lucky
there at the end
um okay next game five night I through
we're probably gonna do this dance a few
times now so II six probably Bishop g2
I'll Castle someone says would you play
the Kings gambit or the more um I'll
consider it the more would be more apt
considering the tournament I think I
think estimates here playing the
tournament mark a sermon from the US who
wrote a book on Smith Morris so if I get
the chance let's run I play but I don't
think this guy plays the Sicilian DC for
now this looks wrong so I can take the
pawn b7 so it takes I'll take rook b8
Bishop c6 and it looks like I'm just up
a clean pawn now I can play 92 maybe but
I'll just take the pawn I'll be greedy
and now okay so what is the material
account I am up a pawn follows retreat
to Bishop a7 is hanging here
I won't grab the pawn and blacks me an
issue here is that uh his King on a fade
is not developed and so this rook on h8
can't can't get into the game quickly
like be a torque see it aren't possible
Don people in do ask what which region
do you stay when you're in Italy I'm
normally in the Naples region so that be
Campania
nyeeehhh for okay so I'll play with c1
so you take so we're gonna play some
long end game now I'll play see seven or
eight three I think I'll play Bishop c6
try to try to get this a pawn moving now
it's over k5 so first things first I'm
gonna kick the bishop out at about five
so that the diagonals closing yes to
retreat I'll play a four don't play f3
protect protect the pawn on e4 me
believe it should be five and a move or
two and now it's Bishop is also how to
play like he needs to push this pawn to
in order to bring the bishop back so he
plays out five so I'll take it takes
with the bishop now I'll play rook e1
I'll play rook e1 trying to put some
pressure here on its c6 pawn and also
maybe this would be five and a mover to
so no no I'll just look there should be
five but the real Kanye wanting to be
able to take because I mean that a1 work
would be hanging so h5 play rookie to
just stop anything here on the second
ranks I want to put my King on g2 and
now there are no Chuck's g5 and I could
play it I'll play h3 I'll get I'll give
them g4 probably he'll play g4 create
another outside pass pawn king of to
play rook d2 I can always sack on f3 too
if I absolutely have to if there any
real issues
crunching night posted a tweet I mean
I'm not gonna load a video if that is a
video but are they trying to say that
Eric and I can do some kind of multi
stream or something
I'm sure that's possible later on at
least but but anyway we'll see that's a
rook f7 so now I'm gonna play with c4
try to exchange some rooks off the board
he loses the rook then all I'll check so
I basically I need to exchange in pieces
here because I need to try and improve
my position now here it's worth noting
he's also put his pawns on light squares
which is which is very bags and a bishop
endgame he could be easily losing now so
now I'll play Bishop e2 all I gave him
bishop c6 maybe that wasn't quite ideal
although if I get the two pawns this is
winning mm it I think it is actually if
I remember this correctly I think it is
but I'm pretty sure that was some that
was a kramnik I think it's Carlsen
Kramnik actually with the two jean age
pawns against the against the bishop
clicking III b5 will play with c3 for no
chuckin and actually now this is just
technically winning so I'm gonna be able
to force rooks off the board and was
rooks off the board he's about to light
square pawns I mean work a6 is my next
move obviously so
and that's why if you're in bishop
bindings you've got to be very careful
with what what color squares you put
your pawns on because my opponents can't
be attacked of both of his pawns could
be attacked so 83 e6 maybe e4 maybe not
okay he's gonna play the same a3 as he
did last time so we're gonna get
something relatively normal I take C 597
this should be five but a6 this looks a
little bit unusual so let's see what he
wants to do here so there should be two
so I can exchange or not exchange I'm
just gonna play it on game because I
don't see any good reason not to give me
two castles someone says I'm dodging
Eric's challenges I don't feel like Eric
has actually challenged me a very long
time so that would be surprising I
should white ago p5 I just give me a
four for no reason I was stupid hmm I'll
go before though
let's see for bishops e7 a5 now I'll
play Bishop c6 try to put the bishop on
this other diagonal maybe he'll go an
IBD to back I'm not sure really
so plays Knight e3 which is a little bit
weird my knight f6 yeah 3 I could good
night h5 force g3 and then SAC maybe
maybe yeah why not let's let's see after
super wrote this article that I am that
I I like rooks more than I like two
pieces I have to go for something like
this and by that so Greg Suhr for the GM
wrote an article I believe on trust calm
about this topic saying that I prefer
two pieces to on to Bishop and and night
I think it was something like that so
there should be three over c8 put my
books on the ideal squares here towards
the center so d5 some move but I think
maybe I can just take and played Bishop
c4 try try to exchange more pieces off
the board because less pieces is going
to give me more chances to create create
winning chances here on the King sites
rook you won Brooke you want it's a big
move I actually didn't see that's g6
King D 3 I'll play rook c5 try to pick
up this a5 pawn
although even though it's it's not clear
I think the worst is past has passed for
me now I think I should be completely
fine
so all right let's see sir okay one I
could take I promise just play b3 keep
this keep this pawn on the board come on
play it work b5 to protect it and this
way now also now I've got this free free
free H pawn to push down with works now
his work is a little bit like this work
doesn't really belong on e3 no I'm just
gonna start pushing on the kingside her
Chuck
MERP c8 rook c8 just wins the rook so
you just retired
okay so chess spirits I'm afraid of Eric
yeah I I didn't know that that's the
first time I ever heard that but I good
to know good to know that people think
I'm afraid of Eric's only after beating
him every time we've ever played um so
that's that's always a first anyway so
he castles Oakley Knight c4 Queen e7 I'm
just gonna take the bishop and just play
Knight f3 because now I've got two
bishops as well so it's now I could give
up the two pieces again but I'm not
gonna do it this time so it's only one
pawn hey six hopefully push me to be 494
see if he wants to take or play Knight
e5 c5 there should be two so someone
said Eric is waiting for me I don't even
see Eric online right now so I'm a
little bit confused as to what people
are referring to so yeah three work out
three and I've got again I've got this
really nice diagonal and his pieces are
a little bit loose again like 95 Bishop
c4 doesn't quite work I'm gonna play
with g3 put pressure here on this Kings
I mean this is really starting to get
ugly though because now I can play
Bishop c4 I'm at threatening to just
take on d5 and take off 6 with my bishop
like this is really quite ugly
so he plays b5 now I could take I could
take right away but I don't actually see
it so I'm just gonna play it this way no
I'm just gonna play d3 and I want to
play E for and close the diagonal so
that he doesn't get something along this
8h one diagonal
the meantime so I could play efore but I
think I'll think it's all play Queen d2
first maybe I want to put the bishop
back and then the Queen on c3 it's one
thought I mean actually it makes a lot
of sense yeah it's not no I'm not queen
c3 will be just game over kindness so b4
- stop that and I'll play E for side
close diagonal and I get myself to Sage
six square for my queen to place d5 he's
trying to open it up again so I don't
know if I can avoid it though now d5 d6
d4 yeah I don't really have a choice
okay I just kind of have to do this so
oh well rookie seven what does rookie
seven my calculator offline now workout
six is just crushing if he doesn't play
T force but the problem now d4 is that
I'm gonna get rook f3 and I'm gonna
control the file completely yeah cuz now
he's gonna to go rook e8 and I think
after rook e8 workout southern is just
game over
although he doesn't work cheese
sovereign don't you see it's an all
played Bishop c1 maybe I can get a
Bishop teenage sex and I'm just Rick I
feed Chuck mate
so why not Queen h4
and robot rights do you know you're
playing a female this guys and I am so
I'm pretty sure he's not he's not a
female I don't believe but what do I
know anyway I mean I guess it could be I
mean but who isn't who would it be
I mean I I don't want to flip the screen
since I'm streaming but if it is
actually I mean I I don't know what is
the country Kazakh Stan I thought I I
don't know who it is it could be that um
isn't there a really talented female
player from as exact Sanders Becca Stan
I I don't know which country it is but I
thought this was a guy but anyway what
do I know
so Bishop c8 I'll play Bishop out for
Rookie 7 I'll check
I'm gonna go Bishop d6 next move in now
like now again all his pawns are on the
wrong
we're on color like the whole house just
collapses right away it's just like
terrible again it's obvious of color
bishops up of blacks down you know 500
pawns okay
53 e6 maybe this game I'll get the am I
gonna get Eliana we gots Magnus oh I
played an IP detune on Knight c3 how sad
Queenie - I'll play c5 c3 I'll take 94
CD for CD for Elsa makes us all tonight
c6 e 597 oh and of course yeah since
it's been so long since i streamed you
guys if to you
if you wants me to play it's curtain
opening or do something crazy you can
just go ahead and make a donation I'll
I'll do that so it's been so long since
I've streams that I kind of forgotten
about that
so g4 I'll take like Queen c7 I don't
know if I'm actually gonna get an attack
over here or not but I'm okay now in a
playoff sex let's let's see this would
be - I'll take takes I can Castle
probably very shaky I'm gonna put the
King on f7 looks very ugly but I don't
know maybe I can get something I'll go
rogue h3 work h8 I mean I'm kind of in
some trouble here this is not really
what I was hoping for when I played g5
but maybe I can maybe I can suck out
something so go Queen d8
94 I mean this is not really very pretty
I could play 95-96 Queen and now
it's no good so I'm gonna I'm gonna take
play a 5 try to try to open it up
somehow over here takes tags and now
I've gotta come up with a plan first
plan is how to okay I'll play if I play
Knight betta I want to go knight c6 now
so probably he'll play b5 and to stop
nightsticks and I'll go back to d7
because now at least I'm gonna get the
c5 square for my knight so hubba bubba
bubba writes why do you guys like
garbage openings well it is online chats
after all you guys but I'm generally
most most players prefer to avoid
showing preparations they can especially
online so that's the actual reason
Astra Natasha nave rights aren't you
playing Carlson later today in the
tournament last round did happen earlier
today so the tournament action is
already I mean at least for me it's all
for but but there still are some games
going I didn't actually look to see
those who's playing but there are there
are some games still going so Queen c1
I'm gonna go King drew some just get my
avoid this hane Chuck maybe 23 I'll play
Knight c5 back I mean probably I'm gonna
try to redevelop my bishop because this
Bishop errant b7 is terribly placed it's
got no scope whatsoever so I'm probably
try to get it to like d7 eh e6 something
like this I mean something something
along these lines
92 f4 is not really an idea here so he
wants to go tonight h4 night h5 I guess
so I'm gonna put the fish 28 g6 page 5
and now I've got to be a little careful
I'm gonna go King off seven tonight at
night if six really interesting so now
he's threatening to take the pawn on c5
I can go Queen e8 doesn't really do a
whole lot but why not might be three
attack the bishop on d4 I could have
gone 94 then it would have gone Queen
now for so this this makes a little bit
more sense
so please Bishop takes b6
okay so I'll put Queen a1 I mean he has
no checks right off that's the good news
the bad news is that I don't have Bishop
d3 here either so I'm gonna be the Queen
e1 threatened Knight d2 I guess he has
cleanup for Bishop d3 maybe
so he goes Bishop e3 update e4 d3 let's
let's just push this pawn to D one make
a queen and I think he's I think he's my
stuff because now d2 is almost
unstoppable this position looks so bad
for black I mean it was bad it wasn't
terrible though it wasn't losing so I
mean a real game would be losing but
this is splits after also d2 probably
takes
Tigs but I mean White's just lost here
because I'm just making a queen or
taking with a knight now if one's gonna
hang
a fxq brights the way he drinks the
water he looks like an alcoholic okay
good to know good to know
Archer nitrites do you play any video
games um I don't really play that much
anymore I used to play play some video
games I mean I don't know if you do mean
like on the computer you mean arcade
style I mean I used I used to play some
Starcraft that's the only computer one I
like some really old old fighting games
like Street Fighter especially back in
the day but those days are long gone
jeetu probably castles castles d54 it
was pretty standard kind of copycat type
styles and c4 takes you can't take on c4
Sunday we came to the shrunk b7 so Queen
b8 that's a weird move it split Queenie
to simple develop the rooks D 1 C 1 I
mean now I just get me knight c6 and now
I was just gonna lose in exchange for no
reason takes c b3 I can't take with the
night or the pawn will turn illogical I
think taking up the pawn makes slightly
more sense just so that I can maybe put
up on him be for later and avoid and
putting a knight on c5 taking what
tonight also would make sense
I guess he's fed up with his position so
he just resigns b6 Bishop d7
there should be three e6 play another
another Owens defense might have three
I'll play Knight f6 maybe D to t5 I mean
we're probably gonna play the same thing
again as last game but this time I'm
gonna improve I'm not gonna play as bad
it's gonna take I'm gonna play Knight
bd7
or Bishop b4 actually a this would be
for shock so he's probably gonna play
Bishop d2 I would assume
so he does I'll take maybe place night
fd2 maybe I can take a d4 okay just
please 92 so 0.8 c6 now he's got this
ice on d4 this isolated pawn on d4 which
is kind of bad it's not terrible but
it's it's a little bit on plastic so
imma play 97 95 or 96 I'm gonna go to g6
I like it a little bit more Queen Queen
oo rights can you approve Chaka Khan
friend request for donation I believe I
can I feel like I don't for some reason
I don't know if it's a page or what it
is I generally end up not accepting the
friend requests but right I can check
that out and probably do that but that
should be a request that I can
accommodate someone says that 10 oh can
you get Erika shot I mean I'm confused
am I really missing something I don't
see Eric online right now unless he lost
like 100 points I see
Gordy's ana anat nuki I mean I just
don't see him so okay so Queenie 3 on
the play f6 solidify this pawn here on
g5 tonight on f4 mate c4 I'm gonna play
a queen d5 put pressure on this long
diagonal 92 it just goes right back so
now it's time to like to try to pounce
how to pounce I'm gonna play rock ad 8
simple move put the rope on a good
square although I did give them Rosie
sobbing a little bit a little bit wrong
but not terrible yet so I'll play e5
take if he takes the hint shucks me at 1
on g2 if not have 90 to check things are
starting to to hang a little bit so it's
getting a little bit ugly now
Queen b3 I'm just gonna exchange Queens
and I just take the knight on f3 and 92
shotgun unless he has rook c8 then I
just go rookie 8 yeah this is pretty bad
it's d3 there should be 2 play III
Knight f3 knocks move obviously play d4
maybe e6 I don't know what he's gonna do
now
so we'll see Queen d7 h I'm gonna put a
bond III I'll play a 3 first
prevent any night before stuff you know
I'll go c4 Knight h6 okay let's play
Bishop d3 actually I should check to see
what um what is happening in the other
games in the meantime since I didn't
actually look I'm gonna lose like ten
seconds on that take a look at the other
game so so Vichy one we're poor drew a
Leon I'm still playing
we know Oh donated $10 okay so yeah so I
will take care of that give me one
second you guys let me try and win this
game
you know oh thank you for the donation I
will get on that after this game
probably it's a beef c5 let me see let
me you figure out where is that page um
chest up calm well
okay give me one second you guys okay so
let me try and finish this game first
okay so hb7 I'll play be for someone
asked what race I plan on Starcraft um I
really like the Terrans I mean the
Protoss obviously are the fastest or the
hardest um I was I was a big fan of the
of the Terran though I really like siege
tanks and then I probably I would say
yeah I liked tearing the most and then
then Zerg I'm playing the original
Starcraft that is by the way not
Starcraft 2 I haven't I don't think I've
actually ever played Starcraft 2 so I
mean well in when I was there I really
liked lurkers lurkers and guardians to
two of two favorite units for attacking
on the ground so um c6 so I don't really
know he's got this this weird setup on
the kingside I'm gonna play Bishop c1
maybe trying to do something here on
this diagonal thing play E 4 it's a
bishop d8 so he wants to put his bishop
there okay um how to progress I'm gonna
play Knight off one I don't know if what
I'm doing is right either
but yeah somehow it doesn't look right
but whatever okay I'll take I'll play
Knight e3 so he takes now I can keep it
to each punt or the F pawn I think
that's better to take with the F pawn
just because of this the way his pawns
are here I'm not sure but it looks right
so he's trying to go all in on the Kings
side I mean I'm not too worried cuz I'm
a queen but he can't really play h4
right away and now I just wandered for
no good reason that was very stupid if I
take he could just take to take the
rogue so I'm down on time I've got a
terrible position so this is gonna be a
tough one
let's see let's see if I can do the
streak alive
okay so I want to do that fun I'll play
rock out for I'll give me H for I'm not
too worried there's 96 and I don't have
anything better than their just retreat
that's unfortunate
okay I'll put a bishop and a one-stop
age for I'm gonna go Queen C to work out
for and work a - I'm gonna try to put my
rook on e - that's that's my goal and
Lena are zero zero thank you for the
thank you for the donation the player K
- I mean I'm not sure I'm gonna go work
that for I think I will go th one I mean
he's trying to squad me basically so I'm
have to be fast now whoops
okay so I'm gonna try to try to open it
up here on the on the UH whoa what is he
doing dude dude you have a minute and a
half
why you pre moving come on dude
that was really weird
very weird so okay one second
c3 e6 okay so this is Owens this is the
the earth okay a3 this was the a Leonov
Carlson game um it isn't anymore cuz he
played a t3 and d3 although already
block is completely fine here so he 597
people keep saying I'm dodging Hanson am
I am I just like insane or something I
don't see him on the list
ah there he is now he's online okay now
he's finally off okay now I see well I
think Erickson you got a chance to play
me later in person over the board before
the closing ceremony in like three hours
so I think Eric can wait a little bit 92
I'm just gonna take make sure he doesn't
get c3 endless long pawn chain literacy
8c3 a 5 we need three nights five Queen
B five I'll move my king queen III
probably the best move
Oh Fish Face six months old and
everything's falling off the tables so
trust me donated $20.00 play Eric Hanson
haha okay let's see okay so I will play
last two I'm gonna get it an even 14 on
then I'll saw
a six Bishop d3 tape stakes just play a
three I'm gonna start playing weird
moves not just to try and win these acts
to get really fast because obviously
playing eric is gonna be interesting
everyone seems to think that I'm afraid
of him suddenly be eight points you to a
five I'll just play with Casey one maybe
six I don't know if that actually
accomplished before I could take I can
play c5 I'm just gonna take on f6 don't
even know why but for some reason I'll
do it too and then I just hung a pawn on
e4 but he missed it
Cal + c5
crime has become a bit of a weird
position no I'm not really clear so you
please age six up late night after our
boy it's hanging v3 geez terrible
terrible what what was dude Wow okay so
one more and then then it's Eric time I
assumed about to play Queen B - I mean
that's very very strange but someone
says the name of Eric's thing is called
hunting hunting what's hunting is like
The Hunt for Red October or something I
mean come on
so 9 c 3 d 5 Richard G 5 90 d7 83 Bishop
e7 Queen c2
I'll just castle
someone calls what NACA hunting what
does air Eriksson Lee think he can beat
me or something
come on
so anyway alright this this guy's super
slow and grind bxb now now there's
there's a real fan the problem with
hunting is that sometimes the whale eats
you yes that's that's exactly how I feel
thank you um I'm not dropping his queen
okay whatever else pleurisy - although I
just given Bishop b5 that was very
careless of me
very very carrot but actually I Bishop
f3 so I'm okay yes rookie Argonaut says
we're gay but then he has Queen C sub I
me probably also very good but but
anyway and now he wants to have some
kind of weird weird discussion about
analysis during the game very strange
anyway
okay I don't know what's with this guy
he's very strange he's basically saying
I missed a winning winning line even
though it's still a great position now I
just gave me a brocade anyway but now I
know I don't want it oh just or do I
want it do I want it or to be or not to
be okay Queenie push great but see - not
very attractive I'll just take the pawn
castles I'll take vg5 Knight f6 I mean
yes it was probably better than what I
did but not a big deal
Queen c7 and play what will I play I
just want to somehow win this game
quickly I'll be page 5 Queen g3 g6
Burke FBI wanna clear up t to probably
work d1 or Bush both wanna know knows my
oopsie one okay I'll play I'll play else
are playing we're so I'll play f5f for
even though it's probably quite wrong
about for Knight f6 got e for geforce of
juicy squares for the nights now I mean
this night can go to g4 or efore plays
f3 really I'll play Knight d5 tapped
upon
III 31 no no flavor CA try to double the
rooks on the 7th rank and then I then
everything is gonna fall to pieces h3
okay I mean I have to double Wow Queens
you over what I just take Chuck
me okay so where's Eric
where is Eric time to hunt him time to
hunt the Eric okay Eric alright so just
for a couple minutes I'll probably be
slightly slower here in the chat much
more likely to take this very seriously
just like in beat Eric can't give him
any advantage on the clock either
it's a d5 d6 9241 v6 I calculate a four
I could have played out for also I mean
everything's really possible here I'm
gonna play c3 though now I'll play out
for b5 I'll take take it be for put a
knight on c5 from V 3 then this b5 pawn
is likely gonna become weak later on
because eric has a bad pawn structure
now ok 97 Knight be 395 26 reasonable um
no I've got to figure out so do I want
to start acting on the kingside - oh my
could I think I'm just gonna read
redevelop my bishop okay just play
Bishop e3 takes four okay Queen B 1 for
K 3 I can play Queen B 296 I'll just
retreat my bishop
a chart probably is wrong because now
you might have some weaknesses here on
the kingside later on and yeah now I'm
gonna know I'm the Goff I'm gonna try to
expand her on the Kings side it's Queen
c7 okay I'll play Bishop g3
and I'd c4 or up like aah to protect the
bishop Iran g3 maybe play four out five
plays Bishop d8 play Knight e3 and
ninety-five next move so now I can you
can take or not take please work a
throughout the Queen see one there to
Kingi one Queen a7 strangeness all take
23 Bishop d7 I mean probably I'll take
or play d5 d5 doesn't quite work here
probably so I'll just play well I play
here I could take and play rookie to
this d5 take steak steak steak steak
scorpion can you 7 or D 8 D for takes TC
riff D 1 C 2 C 1 rupee to work C 1
options options what to do oh why not
i'll go for it i'll try to make it
interesting let's see
please Queenie 1/8 okay fair enough I'm
gonna play d1 no I can't it you can
still take
it's take I can play Queen f3 or queen
bee for I'm gonna play Queen out three
stalls birthday one I'm gonna take and
go kimchi - if d4 I just go Queen d5
let's clean B - a little bit off - Queen
d2 five
six fish about four here I guess or
queen you know for Ben I'll take d5 King
off one grab a pawn grab another pond 53
Queen d4
and now Chuck doesn't make sense
23 does make sense
oops
there you go Eric flag this one okay
game - let's see what what prep Eric has
in the Berlin today
oh he's gonna play Bishop c4 so he wants
to play a JUCO now so c3 Knight f6 d3
d6a for it six I mean this is all pretty
well known castles castles you can play
d4 Bishop g5 or p1 many different moves
here
says I'm furious huh what what I'm
furious I'm confused
I won the game on time oh I didn't say
like I said flag
I said flag no I'm not lag anyway okay
so all right rookie one what will I play
here I'll play base 7t 297 right
off one plate b5 there should be six
it's all pretty pretty boring
oair Eric's a black well yeah Eric it's
always good to have excuses I wish I
wish I had some excuses too
and Eric's talking about lag Eric's also
here in the Isle of Man so I don't know
what he's talking about any life that he
has I should have to so I don't really
get that there should be three I could
take the Queen see six also or just take
on d4 maybe I'm not really crazy about
that so I'm just gonna go see six
because now the Queen also protects the
fish money seven sir do you want weensy
seven and Eric's gone wrong no it's it's
still interesting but I feel like
White's kind of lost that's right a
little bit here so now I can take on c4
I want to I don't have to I'm gonna play
Queen b7
well I did just give night at five Navy
which I kind of overlooked so now I can
which way do I want to place don't wanna
take and take on c5 take the double
pawns yeah I think I'll take the double
pawns here on on f6 if you wants to
write a five and play well this might
have been wrong so I forgot that this
this pawn here on age six is a little
bit loose it's looser than I realized it
was so now what will I play how to
figure this out because yeah that's kind
of has gotten really obvious hopefully
rookie six like Queen b8 and Queen f8 I
guess I'm and this is not really ideal
but it's not I don't think it's lost on
the spot okay Queenie to looks like a
bad move so now I can go rook e8 and now
like somehow all my pieces are on the
right squares more or less it's not
completely but more or less because now
it's like my knight here on G so this is
good I clean my works everything's kind
of coordinated quite nicely
so takes tanks I mean obviously Y it is
still quite a bit better here but I'm
not sure how much butter white really is
in fact now I'm not sure why it's better
at all
so please Knight take c1 okay take on b4
Knight f3 what does Knight f3 do if I
take he wants to go Queen c6 is that his
idea it looks work east six though I
don't see it
okay Brooke d5 we can play Knight at
four if I want to and I do want to or 56
rookie - maybe I mean this is actually
not anywhere near as bad is it I thought
it should be
so he goes rookie to play Queen c4 or no
I'll play Queen c5 foursome to exchange
the Queens
so let's see what's he gonna do saris
being on the right square what I meant
is there's harmony everything's
coordinated obviously the clean uh knife
it was not perfect but it wasn't
terrible either 1996 just King g7
I'll go king of fate make him take oh
you just wants to a king - fine I'm
gonna start running this beep on man
I mean the problem for Eric here is he
also has no time so on top of just being
in bad shape he's got no time
all right that's too
so let's see it's a third game what if
there is Eric saying he wants me to play
you for or against him or something like
come on Eric bring bring your A game um
what's this play might be five or just I
don't know what am I gonna do here um
I'll just play Bishop a1 something
called something slow maybe not maybe I
feel I'll just a put the Queen if he
takes on d4 maybe can I please come via
can I go Knight d5 and now he starts to
have real problems here anyway as I was
starting to say though before I mean as
the saying goes from the matrix I mean I
think it's what's it stop stop trying to
hit me and hit me I think that's what I
feel like saying to Eric right now
because he's uh his his play has not
quite been there and he's capable of
better so works he's seven I'm just a
fish mastery I mean his position is
really really ugly bad pawn structure
bad bad pieces I mean I could take it no
I can't take don't calculate B for now
it just takes and I'm just gonna win an
exchange thank you very much
so that's it's a 95 I'll take might be
seven yeah
24 his plants are so bad that I mean
it's it's hard to Tomaso sob but I could
it's always possible play work see -
nothing nothing - flash you're fast
just simple slow chose weights III don't
play up threes no 94 now just slow calm
relaxed me rook d6 is coming in a mover
297 what's Knight be something do
exactly just rip d4 I know I thought I
thought that was Morpheus from the
matrix actually when he says in the oh
he says stop trying to hit me and hit me
because I what is it fight clubs what
that's what the what's it first real
Fight Club is don't talk about Fight
Club second rules don't talk about Fight
what's that second is don't talk about
Fight Club third rule is was a third
rule third rule is no rule cypher Africa
I forgot the exact lines from Fight Club
okay so we're gonna play a Berlin this
time so or yeah we're gonna plant I
guess so okay let's see what Eric
hazardously this time it's three I'll
play age six six pay for b5 - d5 -
Bishop e6 a four could play which one do
I want I'll just play d4 this time make
it interesting
[Laughter]
very funny comment yeah that's that's
not a trick that's actually my my my
trainer where we're staying the same
room here at the Isle of Man so a very
very funny comment so Bishop d2 what's
he trying to do
Bishop c3 I guess I'll take though if
you take some play before I think so
probably I'll take with the pawn right I
expected that now I'll just play Oh play
rook b8 or Queen d7 I'll play more Queen
d6 now if like we do something I
probably he'll take on d5 over soon
submission III so he wants me to take so
he can get the square um I could take
each three now that doesn't look right
well this play work 88 I'll take double
pawns I'm not too worried
so take stakes now I may be threatening
to take so he goes 92 I'm gonna go for
the kill now I'm gonna try to put my
knight on now for I'm gonna try to just
just meet him he can always take on e5 I
guess but we'll see I don't think he
will so he goes rook b1 so he's really
asking me to sack but I'm gonna I mean
Knight f4 rookie three I could I could
sack now know is he is uh is that sorry
so I can't sack so I'm just I'm just
gonna sack up on and just play something
positional here so b4 he takes before
just b5 fixed the pawns now as d3 pawn
is really weak I mean I'm still down
upon so I should be worse but it's not
that bad
so o is is Eric streaming and he's antes
he's listening to my commentary the pack
Oh Eric how funny
so now I'm gonna tack upon here on B for
this actually might not even be worse
for me anymore because his his pieces
are really misplaced here d3 is week b4
is week I mean everything's kind of
loose here
so please night-night f1 I'm gonna play
rook c8 try to put some pressure on this
this bishop on c2 cuz it's it's also
pretty terrible here now I'm gonna go I
could play Knight d4 yeah why not but a
crook g3 work f3 he wants play work f3
and get got some e5 in so I'm just gonna
play Queen e5 and rook c3 and okay so he
plays Queen d2 h e5 support the night
here on f4 93 play rook c3 I will no
reason not to maybe - no I don't have to
I could play rope CA alright takes takes
yeah but why do I want to roll my pawns
actually no I'll take playoff five yeah
I'm actually all of White's pieces here
it is terrible it's rook on f3
especially it's just like this rook on
f3 is just horrendous here I mean all of
White's pieces are just terrible
so g3 ripped f8 King eh - now I can even
just yeah I'm gonna take up take there
now I'm gonna play workout for I mean
whites whites in bad shape here it's
like there's about seven maybe H 5 H 4
is coming now
in fact what is this review for h5
he takes three-piece three-piece Eric
three-piece now I can play workout 3 but
you know I've got I've got all the time
in the world I can't why rush let's just
slow it down bring the rook back and
just like crush him and what's he
threatening does he have an actual try
he does he's trying to bring the Queen
the back rank okay
so how to stop him I'll just play
something safe I'm also so far up on the
clock that I mean realistically he's got
no hope so
all right that's for
so takes 94c for
I'll take 95 93 all pretty standard so
far 22 a 5 what is a 5 / KD 1
each five who Eric's trying to meet me
or something come on dude what are you
trying to do now I do have c5 here and I
think I'm gonna play it because it looks
like a good move
take it takes and play Knight b5 I can
play Bishop b5 I've got so many good
moves here almost to money but I'm gonna
play Bishop e5 got to be careful I don't
allow some Knight f3 nonsense but
fortunately it doesn't quite work here
so Eric please knight c6 now I can take
the pawn that would be a logical thing
to do but I'm gonna play 92 I'm just
gonna play positionally because Black
has this terrible pawn on d6 that is
really really quite poorly placed so I
could take the take on e5 and play Queen
c3 can also just move my queen I thought
so just play 94 in fact why not
pretty much everything looks really good
here for white sets now can't I take I
still tasted the bishops at Bishop takes
Bishop takes takes takes and I could
exchange at all do I really want to play
that kind of game no I'll play Knight f3
so probably takes takes Bishop g4 bush
me - I mean I've kind of miss played
this slightly I'm so much better but
it's not it's not as better as it was
oh oh I should start suggesting bad
lines is Erik like listening to me or
something if your ex actually listened
to me that would be really funny okay
Ricky eight others complain it4 and I
mean miss Bishop 1984 Bishop takes h3
what she completely missed so I got to
be a little bit more careful okay so how
do how to convert this I'm gonna play
off three I'll take I'll take flip
Bishop c4 maybe d5 maybe not actually
probably has to because this King on GA
this this long diagonal is really bad
for black one to just protect the pawn
here on EE - now I'm gonna try to expand
you're on the King side a little bit so
takes now I'm now I'm turning me to go
King tree - and that's Queen before
doing you know there just give him d4
that was unnecessary but I've got a form
d8 now I'll play we need to try to
exchange some some some pieces off the
board maybe maybe maybe it's not best
but I've got Queen h6 coming as well I'm
so queen e7 a little - you know 16
G - now I'm gonna double to Brooks on
the edge file a 4 mm up / k8 is it okay
to actually do does it threaten anything
I don't see what it threatens I'm just
gonna get my king out of the way of any
any tricks
so Queenie fine now I can play a four
I'm gonna play off for why not
between a five what there's no checkmate
here wait a second I guess there is no
meat oh wait can I just take him please
chief five and time to resign Chuck
meeting one on on h7 thank you very much
that's five
councils get one let's move your
base seven three I mean their money
moves her I'm gonna play B five six
maybe to be four
there should be six see what he wants to
do trip d2 this is a little bit weird
I'm gonna take play d5 I'm gonna play
Knight d7 though maybe I'll five at some
point night c5 many different ideas here
wait who says he has a winning position
Eric says he has a winning position last
game well what Eric had a winning
position huh what what am I missing here
Bishop a4 now I could take the take the
knight but I'm just gonna move my knight
back to you sobbing no need to get
overly cute here 93
I could play Knight c5 I could also play
f5 which is kind of interesting there
that 95 - 52 Knight b3 isn't one option
yeah it looks looks like reasonable
takes Queen e2 maybe f5 I don't really
want to play up five minutes guys
simplify so I'm gonna play hu6 try to
put a night here on a four and I could
play Knight f4 here but it doesn't
really make sense I'm just gonna treat
my Bishop d4 click Queen c8
tonight h-43 obviously wants me to take
so let's play King h7 as long as there's
no meat throughout here on age six just
got to be slightly careful here
I could play work beat network b2 hangs
that so if I take take with me to you oh
Allah
okay so let's see just got to be
slightly careful here and I still don't
see it so if you goes clean x5 I just
take the knight on the h4 so he plays
work b1 now I'm gonna take the knight on
h4 mine I take the rope no wait wait I
can just take the rook isn't this just a
free pot what are you doing Eric
now I had the e5 discovery shock but I
just moved my king bishops III so he's
trying to create something over here on
the Kings side I play off five I don't
have to I like a five there just close
the diagonal plate for g5 play for play
Bishop f2 is now a threat also there are
a lot of threats rook e1 oh come on
that's six four more to go four more to
go
who's the hunted now who is the hunted
so now I was gonna try to play something
more standard I guess I mean actually
now this is gonna turn it some kind of
weird open like what I like what Kramnik
would play it was very Kramnik asked
opening probably 6dc 46 probably so he's
gonna he's gonna take yeah not crazy
about this this for block
we need to publicly work d1 rookie one
but should be one or something like that
it's Lucy's night eh five some lik we
need three alright before Bishop b1 see
you know just kick the night back from
c4 put the push it back on D 3e4 also as
possible
what's he tryin playing Knight f5 or
something if I'd be afraid of that I
don't really think I should be this
Knight a5 I'll just take it
he ate so now he's definitely saying he
wants to play Knight f5 so I have to
figure out what I'm gonna do now I can
play Knight e5 looks kind of logical not
the only way I could play chief for
really bold what other moves are there
here let's see II I don't see over me so
I'm just gonna just gonna place that in
game oh so he doesn't he doesn't want to
do it okay well 295 now say for play
Bishop f4 I don't have to but it's one
of the moves and I kind of like like it
so now play Knight a5 I would think but
now if I take take Queen c3 it's a
little bit dices first game that I've
actually don't bet I don't actually have
a great position and out of all the game
so it's a little bit dicey but I still
think it's reasonable so I'm gonna play
g3
now he's probably gonna think for a
while try to find a knockout blow but
I'm not sure if there is one I don't
think there is
make the premium just to see what he
wants to do
but now 1931 don't I he's gonna have to
go 96 now or night h3 maybe okay this is
not so clear actually
now I can play east six here or not I
think I can I could be missing something
this is one of those lines where I could
very easily be missing something but I
think you have to go out six and when I
go h4 and I think I'm I think I'm
winning here I mean unless there's some
trick here 94 I just take the bishop
Queen d6 I just take the pawn right 23
King Jew one night h3 King eh - mr. G -
King true - yeah I don't see a queen d3
kingi one night is 13 Chuy's no checks
on the second-ranked
he's finished
because queen d3 king g1 if 23 king of
to-night ish through his made but queen
d3 kingi one night oh sure King eh - and
then he's just this whole diagonal I
mean he's just completely busted here
okay plays Bishop c4 so yeah so Eric
society is we're just going to play the
JUCO piano every game this this this
match
so let's see so now I place a 5 so
piggish be 6 so tags I'll take now it's
a 4 I'll take my ditch 5 probably Bishop
e3
or he can go into a deep think and said
but also works
so please Defour I saw this movie but
it's hard to believe now if I take I'm
playing okay for what's he doing or not
okay for us I worked before I mean
what's he doing because everything's a
little bit loose here like it I mean
this diagonal is a big problem for for
ye
so please Queen d3 so now I can take on
f3 also I mean this is the other option
I can also play d5 there are a lot of
options here but d5 looks like the
correct idea
he takes d5 now I've got a choice I can
take with the Queen or I can take with
the pawn many many options here now if I
take with the pawn 95 I'm gonna take
with the pawn now 95 I'm just gonna take
on d4
happy New York to be going into a deep
depression you guys this is like he's
gonna get to play me in person in in
like three hours so it's a little bit
hard to go into a depression depression
mode
so mr. elk you donated $5 really
enjoying your streams Thank You mr. elk
you I appreciate it very much
glad you're enjoying the stream glad
you're enjoying the beatdown of Eric
so Queen takes a six is it's actually a
very good move I'll play I'm gonna play
queen eight here
actually I just blunder something Oh
should I just wandered that was very
poor um do I have any tricks here is the
only question I have rook f6 644 nice
take six tanks you know I don't really
have any tricks or do i yeah I just kind
of just wandered this one away I'm lucky
I'm very lucky this actually it's not
it's not me I don't think yeah I'm kind
of lucky that I just don't lose on the
spot but it's still not very good so
tonight at 6 in fact actually it's it's
lost but it's not it's nowhere near as
lost as it should be considering how bad
of a blunder that was
c36 Shan simple int 5 help cover your
adoption he is okay
what does adoption exactly mean by the
way because I'm a little bit confused so
it works see - I don't know if this
works I'm gonna try it this might just
not work
so he does the Bishop d4 he doesn't a
bishop d4 that's what I wasn't sure
about so now if I take check let's see
okay wait wait wait wait what Hey
mmm did I just blender it all away hmm
way to fight wait what am I missing
yeah I don't think this this is gonna
end very well actually I meant I missed
this ninety-two didn't work um that was
unfortunate I've cleaned beef no I know
that I just take let's see he's got no
time actually I should've just moved
quicker
she's got no time here
yeah if I'd actually been faster in this
game
yeah whoa what okay that was lack of my
own but actually I if I'd been faster at
the start when I was up 30 seconds that
never would have happened so that was
kind of stupid that was a little bit
unfortunate but I blundered that Queeny
six so whatever all right so let's say
can we play d5 yeah take but he takes
I'll take and I bring nobody's talking
about everyone keep saying this adoption
but doesn't make any sense to me so
whatever anyway okay there should be two
ninety seventy five other moves
so I'll castle probably see 697 again
somewhere idea is probably ninety-seven
first I would think place a six up to 95
c5 okay out for I don't have to play off
for it feels like a reason try 96 could
take and they've got all this play work
d1 simple simple solved moves fish about
three next probably night at five rookie
one okay so I was like we have to
one just just try and replace my piece a
little bit better here we're not really
ideally placed although after b5 93 94
695 maybe okay just like we nee one I
can play Knight c5 here I don't have to
I can also not play Knight to five if I
play 95 takes takes takes okay I'll just
oh I'll just retreat I'll just play
something say 492 C to work c1 no tricks
no tracks yeah
Tigs takes Queen b6 probably 95 h5 will
play 95 anyway you know I could play h3
I don't really like playing h3 but there
are some issues here like Bishop g4
potentially to be quite an issue so no
because it plays before I could take I
could not take I think I'll play 8
through try to loosen this Queen side
here a little bit now I think mmm off
it's all play 93
so he plays Queen b6 so now I could take
on e4 I don't really want to though I'm
just gonna get my King out of the way
and so now if you take like and just
take takes Queen III promptly so let's
see
oh oh wait if I take these oh really
oops oops oops it's okay whatever
not that was just a complete oversight
on my part see
this is still probably drawing but I'm
not so sure it's trivial because of the
pawn pawns are on the wrong color of the
black
because ya know now he's gonna frost a
little on it with the color of the ponds
[Music]
alright that wasn't the way I wanted to
win that game but I'll take it after
that stupid game before it's always good
to flag Eric so anyway anyway I can beat
Eric and make him sad is always always
good it's a Knight f6 which berlinda's
you want to play so please do a play
Bishop c5 three castles work e8
so age three age six and one has to
wonder ere prepares these moves like eh
three and he chooses not to play here on
Isles Man which is just very
disappointing so he put in so much work
in preparing was age to remove and then
he then he didn't get to use it in the
tournament here
so you could play t4 bishop b6 this kind
of turn into something like a like an
archangel a little bit might be d to
play Bishop d6 tonight f1 probably and
I'll just play Bishop e6 try to exchange
the bishops mmm multiple ways I think
I'll just take her take him if he takes
the pawn probably d5 if he takes with
the Queen probably just Queen d7 maybe
it's not really clear if he should take
with the pawn at the Queen I'm gonna
guess it'll take with the pawn but yeah
so now I'll play 90 786 pretty standard
type stuff before 96 so I'll give Knight
a5 doesn't really worry me so please
manage to know what do I wanted to do I
just want to play Queen d7 and be boring
I think I will
so I'll probably play Knight g4 and oh
he's gonna take with the pawn
interesting I was expecting him to take
with the with the Queen okay no I'll try
to strike in the center of d5 you know
three but now I'm night h4 Queen e2 I'm
just gonna probably take and play rookie
da maybe or he could take with the night
also I guess but I think I'll just drop
the knight back because this pawn on e6
is hanging this rook da just hung the a6
pawn but now I also ignite a four again
so it plays g5 now I can play Knight f4
does it make sense or not I think it
does but I want to just take one more
look so take stakes 905 takes Queen
th528 yeah look it looks a reason why
not
nice it goes Queen G for not cleaning
five okay but now what's the threat
threat is night age six or Queen g5 so
once the Queen e6 takes twenty five
protect g7 protect out for keep
everything solid do you wanting wants to
play with five so I'll play c6 cut them
off for playing this d7 does that create
an actual threat I don't see it a crease
987 as it's right okay so if there is an
actual threat here or is there Bishop D
eight nine th six there is it so he was
two threats he's 96 and he has something
else I don't know what else so I'll play
Queen f6 I don't really like it but I
don't see anything better
I mean f4 is hanging here too which is
unfortunate but not much I can do about
it and even though I've got these
horrible pawns it's not as loss as it
could be certain age six will play Thank
You seven if Knight f7 probably rookies
seven d8 Knight a5 king of seven it's
bad but it's not not terrible not lost
the way that it probably should be
I mean he's gonna have to check King f7
and now I've got rook d2 coming also
so King f1 so I can play rook to you to
enforce a draw if I want
but who wants to take a draw
and this game I'm trying to base with
vlogging
so alright I don't know who's lag is it
mirrors at him who's lagging here is
this mere him is me
miss me lagging or is this him lagging
who's lagging here who's lagging was
this me or him no this is me lagging
okay well that's that's ridiculous but
okay he should have lost that one
whatever okay I'm I think I'm gonna stop
for now then because that that was a
little bit uh stupid unfortunately
that's happening on every stream that
I've done though I've after I've played
quite a while unfortunately had some
game I think there was a game against
Dania sometime ago where I had that
happen where I just like I felt
something similar twenty seconds to two
seconds and then unfortunately like the
last game just like completely locked
out for for a minute so I'll play
someone else on let's see who else is on
actually right now okay I'll play a
wonderful time someone someone different
someone someone new
and as you'll see I'm like Eric I'm not
gonna whine and cry over a stupid
connection issue so there should be six
takes takes maybe maybe something else
ninety-five ULBs Castle where's your
chief five I'll play aged six fish page
four else planning knight c6 I guess
probably off four could be a slight
issue here I mean he can also take maybe
okay I'm just gonna play Bishop eSAB and
get out of this pen put a knight on e4
next move so the castles play Knight d7
takes take something normal it's night
two to play off five I could just take I
think here I'm gonna put my knight on f6
so yeah let's see okay
all right so Queen f3 play what like
I'll play 98 maybe I don't know what I'm
doing this game just playing kind of
drifting aimlessly making some miranda
moves
[Music]
it's a queen age five but now I could
play a five if I want to and not crazy
about the move but it makes some sense
although oh I know 9 f3
I can just play 906 yeah 4
actually I can't take because I'm my
queen would be hanging so play work fe 8
takes takes night 95 there's a little
bit ugly which would be 7
so he plays g4 takes 97 looks relatively
okay um g4 I'll take takes 97 this is a
little bit ugly in fact maybe 90 Sun was
bad maybe I should just play 94 inside
it doesn't really matter
of course he sort of just played Queen
h5 queen g6 and it's probably just
winning for white but now it's no it's
not not too too bad for me in g3 play
work G and I could play g5 nas play s8
perky one yeah there isn't much to be
said about this position it's pretty
this one's pretty draw
although yeah this one this one so it's
gonna be a draw most likely once there
something crazy that I'm overlooking
although I guess and I could probably
try to play this for away
probably Oh a place about fun okay
he doesn't he doesn't want to just
exchange and make the draw interesting
okay ten to seven and I'm not gonna take
a drug so I think I can maybe get in
King off six an e5 and it's same color
Bishop so I don't know maybe there's
something going on here I don't know
doubtful but you never know Bishop d7
Cheney six I'm just gonna bring the king
over
and this time I'm probably gonna try to
flag the guy just like I was trying to
do last game guys Eric we're failed
miserably
so this one let's see so I just pushed
on 64 so I need to got to 114
this one probably I'm gonna flock him
yeah he's got no time okay that was
pretty ridiculous but all right no that
was just ridiculous okay
okay fine I'll go back to playing Eric
if Eric actually wants to play okay
let's see okay - come on Eric oh yeah my
why is he lagging in who's lying three I
have 650 584 f3 takes Knight c3
so takes all I could take either way
I'll take with the Queen in this game d5
Knight G to d6 I'm gonna play Knight d4
try to attack these pawns there's a d7 I
don't have one I Knight a5 but I like it
castles
I will castle I could have counseled
belong to me but made maybe made a
little bit more sense but no big deal so
work out 326 nice take I could just play
something different what am I gonna do
there are takes we're all just little
get off one
so please night chief for so what he
wants to go night eh - I guess that's
his plan if I take he'll take push page
- so I'll play rock h3 so probably he'll
take on a5 and play g6 maybe
yeah suspicions I mean not not great but
not terrible either probably c6 or
Bishop before he's both both ones are
playable so oh hey it's really okay
interesting
so Ricky ate know what am I going to
play push pay three trying to take
advantage of these these weak pawns here
please c4 I'll just take on d4 I think
it'll just take okay I can play Bishop
c5 or 84 I think Bishop c5 makes more
sons D takes now now here's where I have
to be careful so you can take the fish
for the pawn if I take it the pawn I
think taking what the pawn makes more
sons but I could be wrong
d2 and now I'm just gonna play Age 3 and
kick the night away Hiroki is rook takes
e to IE okay but he missed it so that's
that's good but it's still not easy to
play Ashe this I'm gonna go look see 494
this is still very very tricky so okay
I'll play with c4 94 54
after Bishop before makes more sense
discovers the D 2 square so there's no
Forks of my works on F 3 and C 4
mp7 reform get the rooks to better
squares there should be five put
pressure on c7
I think of I think I've got a clear
advantage now because now I can play
work before now and now I'm slowly
unwinding everything because this this
night was great my fish was pretty bad
but now I'm starting to take control
there's now about the D file to now
change rooks King off to g5 I mean I can
play I'm just gonna play c4 I couldn't
play Brooksie it also but this makes
some sense as long chief before I just
take there's no no good discovery so
close h5 or c8 I don't know if this is
technically correct but it should be
winning cuz h4 I'll play a three six B
for some Bishop e6 takes tanks
really king c6 and i can't just take I
think this should be wedding no I'm not
crazy then there's just a winning king
upon endgame are we missing something I
don't understand what am I missing
yeah that's just one okay
okay so Eric wants to play something so
now he's gonna try night up three okay
she's six so I mean I think Magnus plays
against Evita is white early in the
tournament so it's become topical lately
so let's see what he wants to do efore
Castle I've still following this Magnus
game I believe takes Ricky 196 Knight
see it's Reno that's it that's Magnussen
all play or did Magnus no Magnus did
play Knight c3 sorry so of course and
include like rookie one or something
okay I don't know what this episode a
five let's do it's gonna play four he's
just gonna play four be for a
straightaway so I'm just gonna play wave
eat it did in the game you know Bishop
g5 does exactly but could go Bishop e6
yeah this looks reasonable ninety-four
of takes I can just take with the pawn
now I can just oh wait Bishop e5 does
not work got to be careful here
okay so I'll play b6 stop night c5 very
important
so it's a submission beef for Queen d7
seems reasonable
h4 bishop d5 maybe h5 then or or I can
just play h5 too but I think I'll just
I'll just play Bishop d5 here make sure
their rook d8 there should be no tactics
here so this looks quite reasonable now
Queen g4 fish about seven queen of seven
I'll go clean up something
and actually I think Knight Essex was
just winning I think he missed a win but
that's kind of beside the point now so
nice six I guess
yeah I'm actually I'm still kind of here
in the chat but I do as you just said no
Virgil I do I should pay more attention
to the game because Eric Eric is a
pretty good player so it's depending on
it depending on how strong the players
are some people I can spot them time
against Eric I can't really afford to
spot him time I have to play more or
less straight up actually so I spot him
20 30 seconds on the clock generally
it's not going to end very well for me
so I actually have to focus when I'm
playing Eric that's the which is
actually a compliment to Eric so lucky
five I didn't blunder anything yeah it
doesn't look like it play work I mean
got five I guess I don't really like my
position here but his pieces are weird -
he's gotta clean on each one in it there
are no tactics on f6 or g5 basically I
should be fine mr. h3 I'm simply G for
an action I was getting as Queen trapped
with fish beige - especially to work Age
so Oh Bishop f1 how is he still
surviving here no he's not surviving
Queens you to i-5 yeah I mean this this
kingside assortments not not gonna get
it done
thank you to five and I don't really see
anything here from 52 what's about
accomplished exactly takes d4 Bishop c4
even the yeah this is pretty bad
and okay I can take I can put Queen f3
what is the most okay I'll just takes
and since I can just take the pawn on e5
now
[Laughter]
thank you for core for that comment okay
so there should be seven Knight f3 g 6o
we're gonna play the same wine against
efficiency Southern District ge2
councils castles d5 d6 one of the two
okay please d5 I'll play c4 gun although
here my vision want me to not d3 slight
difference play Knight c3 I please see 5
so I can take or not I don't I don't
know I think I'm gonna take I just want
to see what 94 all this tank so taste
salty Queen b3
so clean v6 night at four takes takes or
no not take sake so Queenie seven or
Quincey seven might see five maybe or
Bishop e5 Queenie 736 no I'll just
take Karima bushmaster ii since if he
doesn't do it the the move won't execute
Bishop c6 wish b5 maybe or 95 295 looks
really nice here
so now I can take on c6 I can play like
rook d1 what does he through is he
actually threatening anything now after
we see like Bishop g2 or something I
mean I don't really understand what he's
threatening but I don't understand what
I'm doing all right so I'm just gonna
bring my knight back just beauty safe be
practical don't hang anything there
should be eight I'll play Bishop f3
knight c6 of course now probably I'll
take and play Bishop e5 takes no now
it's just a clean pawn here so this is
this is pretty good I'll just take the
knight I'm gonna go c5 next move now
rocks before start start to pile on
pressure here on the UH on the Queen's I
tried to try to really push this pawn
down before to e5e for Queen g5 we'll
play Queen c2 maybe yeah why not Queen
c2 inch it but no no I'm starting
to push him back because now once the
rook has to go back and I get c6 95 he's
just getting pushed back this pawn if
this pawn ever gets like c7 this should
just be game over
so each horse is trying to play three
songs thoughts plays restocking
so okay so let's see so what you wanna
do
so another Berlin is it gonna play a
night of three no I was gonna clean
house three gun okay
it's 97 ke for all this council
I guess Eric liked his position last
Khmers gonna he's gonna repeat the line
it's 96 93 I'll go back one eight five
three enough now I've got to figure out
what I'm doing here cuz Alaska I didn't
get the greatest position ever but I
still think Knight f5 makes sense so v4
takes takes or key 852 yeah I'll play
push v6
and we were just following the last game
I think unless I'm missing something but
I don't think I am
94 b6
he's gonna play the h4 again so I'm
gonna slightly improve here I think I'm
up to Queen d7 and h5 I'm play Queen ups
up in this game just stop stop any Queen
g4 nonsense anything crazy takes takes
which before what does that that didn't
run anything okay softly rock 88
probably I want to play Bishop T 5g5 at
some point they'll have to be careful
sacks on g5 especially my bish one Queen
these squares so rookie seven probably
will play work a7 I don't know
92 g5
yeah actually as I saw someone that
shots at bullet I mean it's not that I
can't play both want to try it when I
tried to play bullet everytime I mean
there's always some really bad lag much
worse than even in blitz and so like if
I play a couple of games usually it's
okay but anything more than like five
games and just turns into an absolute
disaster so I just lose every game due
to lag
to g4 right so I can I can take out four
but now I'm gonna go Knight h4 I'm just
gonna get rid of this this Bishop takes
contigs I don't know if Bishop d5 makes
sense or not I think I think I'll play
rook e8 first try to try to be tricky
here okay so it plays out three so I can
play I'm gonna play out five I'm just
I'm just gonna open this up here
completely there's almost no way that
white can survive here it's not turning
queen h3 season have to go to work h1 i
or rookie for okay sir key for yeah I'll
play this d5 actually b5 is hanging pose
should have done that instead but Kevin
but now no I can just take this b5 is
hanging
we have five
okay so I think I can go rogue f7 here
Bishop e5 is always available if I need
it I don't really like it the Queen e2
King H through rookie for d4 yeah I'll
just go for it and trusted I'm not
wondering something obvious at the same
time doesn't look like it though take
695 King g6 yeah this is just winning in
94 I just trade the bishops I'm just
lovin this should be winning I mean the
c2 part is too weak
so d5 okay so we're probably to play
something similar to last game
I'm gonna try something something a
little bit off the beaten path I'm gonna
try like fish bait three it's for fish
bait three nights III something
something unusual here make it a little
bit different it's ninety seven three
four
this might not be right actually this
looks a little bit a little bit strange
like maybe I've blundered 95 or
something this doesn't look quite right
somehow but we'll see
so takes takes c4 Bishop c2
okay so he does go for it so he's gonna
take the he's gonna take the exchange
here on a wand I mean it kind of has to
actually if he doesn't there isn't
really much point to creating this pawn
structure okay so see for Bishop c2 I
mean maybe he's just gonna go be five a
six but that still seems weird to play
this one and not take the exchange on
anyone but okay I guess he really
doesn't believe in the exchange what if
he doesn't believe in the exchange and
I'm just gonna get split repeat one c3
I'll play rook e1 those pawns on c3 but
the fish won't see two blockades at
varying very nicely here know what to do
what to do I'll play Bishop a4 try to
provoke b5 here 64 aha aha okay thought
that was ya bish great for is a bad move
but now I've got visual d3 trick so it's
not that bad
Knight c5 I think I just go a5 now
and it's not so trivial I mean I still
think I'm probably in a little bit of
trouble here but d6
and how bad is this let's see so take
stakes
I mean black has to be careful here
that's well it's not just whitey and
then both sides have to be kind of
careful tapes I'll play rip d1 work out
for is there a threat after Queen d5 I
don't see the threat right off
[Music]
Brooke I've to king of to clean he's
working off one yeah I think Eric just
wondered Queen d5x this is this has
gotten bad some way again and I'm sorry
about that you guys just trying to check
the connection see what's happening okay
good
looks looks like I'm still here good I'm
still here okay ninety-seven so now I
think I'm complete g3 maybe because now
I create a square for my King work f6
off for
and now I think you can just yeah I'll
just take the bishop no no need to give
him the entry square so just take the
bishop force him to exchange the rooks
alright see five actually can I just
take tonight yeah I can't
rookie a fish buffet fish my favor Kiev
is my favorite face that's checkmate
okay so Eric's gonna try an English this
time Knight f3 I'll play d5 there should
be seven trip g5 h 6
so my connection is really really slows
on that I don't know why three councils
and 48
this also is a well-known line I think a
rowing play a few years back
Knight takes d5 okay wait a second why
is this not right this is not right for
some reason it takes shuck before 90 to
so now we're gonna do play Bishop g2
Bishop g4 maybe before I think I can
just take the pawn right if I take then
or maybe I have to take on c4 where is
that so takes four before
nothing Queen B - Queen c1 yeah okay so
I think I just have to take the rock
takes e4 and now I'll play Bishop g4
maybe your risk h5 I'll play
hopefully this Beach five
playing g6
whoa what's this 48 still have f6 f6
Bishop g6 now what do I have here maybe
92 is better I actually just spoke I
don't know
I'm also lagging badly this game I think
so let's see okay so Bishop g6 what fi t
check King juice King yourself with your
son King h6 where's the mate
what am I missing here okay so I'm not
missing anything it's just that he he's
just gonna try to play salt and make a
draw okay
oh man did I really just wonder that oof
although somehow I think I'm still okay
which is oh whoa what's what's going on
did he just wonder something too okay
something we're both blender I don't
really understand what's going on
okay
this was an obvious draw but now it's
like not obvious anymore
yeah another connection is getting very
slow against only
uh-uh again I was kind of bad lag at the
end I'm lucky that was on both on Zach
game not just mine although actually
rows are both streaming so action in
fact it's not that surprising that we're
both lagging a little bit I guess
so let's see what he wants to do this
game okay so this time I please might be
d-sub and I'll flick Queen b3 anyway c5
d5
and see if he falls for the trap or not
so he definitely takes I can take a
stroke ad one way way sighs it's not
just bad for block there's a g7 Bishop
b5 Oh does he just have Knight f6 no
wait wait what's again what's going on
now terribly confused he didn't just
play Knight f6 I guess okay I mean
clearly we're both starting to get a
little bit tired and make some really
stupid blunders
someone said please bonk loud Eric to
make him rage quit I mean I'll consider
it
I'll consider it p8 the play Knight c3 I
mean I don't have to move the knight if
I don't move the knight I don't really
know what I'm doing so I'll just play
Knight a form Bishop t5 her action
Bishop Knight g5 depending but he goes
the right way so 27 bit of d5 / kd8 but
now can I take yeah I can take work a
queen bee 655 Queen e7
takes 95 he plays work d7 so I'll take
with the rook now we're in a reef in for
verses 3 and game
it's fine I'll play h4 fix the pawn
structure here maybe go Knight g5 at
some point h5 probably was a little bit
premature ok so now I wants to do
something down here F to g3 something ok
so let's see so how do I exchange the
Knights I don't see an easy way so all I
don't really want to put my night off
for here by plane 85 ft - ok but I've
got to be faster at any rate so I'm just
gonna put my night off for no no he can
take off for a few wants but 95 this is
actually kind of starting to look a
little bit similar to chronic see him
again stone I got set to him on
yesterday a little bit with this
structure but I don't know what 93 was
stupid move
no I'm gonna offer an exchange here try
to okay but he doesn't he doesn't want
to take a drawn-out okay interesting
ah f5s really interesting okay
now I can play 95 if I want to but it's
too is too early I'm way up on the clock
and I want to play a story at some point
it now feels like the right time to go
for it
come on
oh so slow just wide
come on make the move execute Oh gross
Chris wagon that game is awful
it's your move Eric what's going on
mr. G to Bishop g7 we're gonna play this
one again okay
I might say 390 okay so this game is
gonna vary it now he's gonna play
something different
please night BD - I'll play Rocky 94
what to do I'll play aged 6f 6 I'll play
off 6 even though it's probably not the
best move to Queen d7 who's gonna play
work d8 finish development first then
worry about everything else later
I'll give him before I'm not too
concerned about it complete page 3
but I'm really not worried about this
Queen side attack here so he wants to go
b5 so be it doesn't worry me
okay so let's see what you're gonna do I
mean it takes I just take so that
doesn't really work
Queen c1 I'm gonna do something where
I'm gonna put this knight on a five
again
okay ninety-five click Queen c8 if I
need to I can always put the knight on
d6 to protect protect this b7 pawn
hopefully it doesn't come to that but I
can always do it
h3 I don't know what h3 is well plays
five
so now I please see for I can play my ep
6 if I want to or 97 I guess the point
of a tree wants to you want to move his
night off of f3 I guess the d3 is also
hanging here so it's not quite that
simple
it's a Queen c2 now I'll place c5
I'll take obviously C 595 b7 no actual
threats though I guess a southern okay
doesn't much concern me so I wrote d7 I
can take play like monoply bish Buffy
oof
yeah it's completely blundered that one
that's how bad is this is this just lost
urns it's just bad it's probably just
just lost I'm guessing
yeah this is probably not going on very
well but but got a fight on like play
Knight f5 and 96 maybe or 95 maybe
actually not it's 596 probably just put
tonight as close as I can to
I mean this is just completely lost but
okay night see for tonight's before dude
doesn't do anything so we're got five
3c5 I mean this is obviously just
totally busted but it's not losing on
the spot at least takes 95 what do I
have 92 maybe
I can take III and go work F - so your
injury to an item for these two Bishop
d6 this is not so simple for white
anymore fact Eric has completely messed
this up now it's not even
wow that was terrible from both of us
that was not very good anyway alright
yeah I don't really is there just
lagging really badly because I mean I'm
lagging a little too but he seems to be
extremely slow in general so
oh it's he gonna stop now come on air
it's not time to stop it's never time to
stop you got to play more man come on oh
that's very sad very sad very sad okay
well fair enough all right then all fair
enough Eric I guess I'll play you over
at the over at the plank side shortly
during the closing ceremony and then we
can stream from there so I don't know
actually maybe someone can do is
livestream post a video when we play
over at the over at the at the site
before the closing ceremony but we'll
see you anyway so yeah all right Eric
well that was good that was fun um
alright who else is online now time to
play someone else line
and actually no it's not time to collect
the prices on the closing ceremony is
actually at 9:00 p.m. you guys so on so
actually still quite a bit of time
before the closing ceremony but yeah all
right well I guess nobody else really
wants to play right now so I think I'm
gonna stop them for the time being at
all I'll come back again soon and so
yeah until until next time you guys well
keep it real and I hope you enjoyed it
and I'll be back soon so have a good day
everyone take care bye